one time when I was a kid I found a dead
baby bird on the sidewalk and I buried
it and then my dog dug it up and then
ate it and then puked it back up so I'm
not really I'm not really worried about
I grew up a lot for looking up folk and
they always told me about Balu I've
heard about bullet before and I was
gonna try I heard his delicious hey I
regret this excited let's do this this
dark magic and we're about to eat it
what I was taught you're supposed to
like crack the top and then that forms
like a little bowl and then you're
supposed to sip the soup out of it and
then you just peel the rest off and eat
it well that's a baby bird in there
we're taking like a shot
yeah all right Cheers shoes God oh
that's actually pretty good
oh it tastes just like broth delicious
mmm not as bad as I thought it would be
huh
oh it's looking up at you
yeah that's pretty crazy are their bonus
they're very soft you won't even notice
eat that please I noticed the boat
you're lying where I refer to liver oh
they just squished its brains I think I
never thought I would say these words
the fetus tastes good the fetus does
taste good this was common it would not
like freak me out this is just my first
time I was a little bit anxious for my
first time but I don't think this is
that pet if I ate this like even one
more time I'm sure I'd be totally fine
with it is that your hero burger look my
hair I didn't I defeated you
no high five myself here you need
anything I have a lot of respect for the
people who enjoy this this is you're
hardcore you can eat this I don't even
like hard-boiled eggs I don't know why
I'm here